and let's get into that first big story
out of axios this is crazy news
putin orders
russian peacekeeping operations in
eastern ukraine the latest in a decree
recognizing the independent the
independence of the donetsk people's
republic and the lahansk people's
republic putin ordered the russian
military to conduct peacekeeping
operations in the occupied ukrainian
territories the separatists don't hold
all the territory they claim so
recognition could swiftly evolve into
war unless russia limits its operations
to the separatist held areas analysts
have also warned that moscow could also
use any attacks on its troops in eastern
ukraine real or fabricated as a pretext
for a broader war
the separatists declared independence in
2014 and have waged a low-scale war
against ukrainian forces since then with
military backing from moscow the
fighting has escalated since thursday
with kiev accusing the separatists of
persistent shelling across the line of
contact i just want to point out though
um i don't believe the corporate press
i don't know exactly what's going on the
u.s uh is is typically run by
establishment political war mongers who
will lie to justify invading or
triggering a war or whatever
there was a lot of reporting that that
russia would seize kiev and occupy and
then hunt down the supporters of the
president which is all just propaganda
bs
it's a complicated situation you know uh
i mentioned in the intro i have friends
down there and they view this as russia
just building up an excuse to seize more
territory in eastern ukraine because
they don't want ukraine becoming a nato
force but they don't want nato on their
doorstep but i don't know what to
believe to be completely honest i
certainly don't believe vladimir putin
but am i supposed to believe joe biden
or is this all just some some dirty game
i'll say one sorry one one more quick
thing
as this was heating up we got reports
that at the ukrainian embassy they
started destroying computers and and
data
well as as most of us know joe biden was
criminally involved at least i should
say in my opinion it was criminal with
uh barisma and his son getting was 83
000 per month being on the board of
directors for a ukrainian energy company
and then joe biden quid pro quo told the
president fire the prosecutor the
prosecutor was investing investigating
this company and then and then as soon
as he's out the guy who founds it comes
back
it wasn't until donald trump came in the
guy fled the country again so look i
think it's simple my view joe biden's
panicking
joe biden was playing dirty with ukraine
along with the rest of the democrats
probably because they want to they want
to set up you know an oil pipeline going
through ukraine the the cutter turkey
pipeline
when donald trump was president all this
disappeared for four years there was
there was nothing really going on here
what happened then then joe biden comes
back and all of a sudden war is breaking
out it's awfully convenient
i feel like this is actually a good
thing i think in reality what will
happen is they'll take over a certain
chunk of the country
russians look good we look good because
we can say we saved ukraine there'll be
some kind of negotiation the norwegians
or the swiss or someone will come in and
build some kind of peace program they'll
call it the you know kiev accords or
something they'll cover something like
that they'll call peace and it'll be
settled in a way that is
acceptable for everybody enough it's
distraction against the disaster the
russian economy is it's distraction
against the disaster that our economy is
so it's good distraction against all
those things and it sets up china for a
negotiated deal on taiwan
so it sets everything up in motion so i
think this is all great in the long run
for everybody they're all everyone's
gonna be happy meaning all the
establishment will be happy the
individual ukrainians they're going to
be screwed if we have the same troops
we're going to be screwed but the
establishment's going to be just fine
putin is is getting a bunch of you know
pro-russians see where russia
i know our country's a disaster but
isn't it great to be russian and the
same thing over here we're not talking
about how bad our economy is look at the
news it's all ukraine yeah we're not
about how bad things are here it's all
ukraine so we can all talk about that
good distraction life is good and we
settle it without fighting actually
having a battle and that sets up china
to have some kind of negotiation for
taiwan which would be a it'll be a hong
kong type negotiation for taiwan there
are a bunch of these articles that keep
popping up talking about uh what is this
one we have uh from the sun here we go
how russian invasion of ukraine may
trigger conflict in all corners of the
globe in terrifying world war three
expert warns this one's from january
there were there were a couple today
every every week you get a handful of
them and you know obviously people are
already saying the title we used is you
know because i mentioned the fears of it
well the challenge is do i do i act like
these articles based on my bias are all
fake and just say that no one's really
scared about
you know if russia moves into eastern
ukraine will that be the distraction
china needs to move in on taiwan will
china start using similar tactics on
taiwan yep i i think that's a legitimate
concern and then and then if we get
spread thin across the board what's iran
going to do what's going to happen in
yemen with saudi arabia what what's
north korea going to do so i think
there's there's a possibility there but
i do think it's fair to point out
all these big stories that are popping
up like russia would occupy kiev that's
insane yeah
that's not going to happen and also the
u.s i really do not believe
maybe this will come back to bite me in
the ass i do not believe the us will
have active troops in eastern ukraine or
in ukraine fighting with russians
the u.s is going to waggle its finger
and i think it's like you're saying
larry i'm i'd be willing to bet that joe
biden and his people are sitting there
and they're like hey this this russia
stuff is fantastic news for us
absolutely like our approvals in the
gutter everyone's mad at us you've got
protests they're going to do a dc convoy
quick scream war
russia yes and we'll shake our fist and
see i'm strong i'm so strong against
these russians putin's a killer he can
do that very easily it's a smart move
for him to do that
but in reality if there are any u.s
troops there and i doubt there will be
but if there are it'll only be after
they're sure it is a safe settlement
like a north korea south korea type
thing right where we know the odds of
actual war are so slim then we might put
troops there maybe but i doubt we will
the germans still want that russian
energy right and the germans run europe
right the germans couldn't win it you
know in military but they won it
economically so they still control
europe and they want that russian energy
so they're not going to fight a war over
that well actually i mean that's that's
that's the big thing isn't it was the
qatar turkey pipeline sure that western
nato the u.s they wanted to get i bring
it up fairly often because it's
significant to everything that's going
on um and it's more than just this i
mean it's a you you can get reductive
and go beyond why this pipeline mattered
but uh cutter was gonna build the
pipeline going up through syria and
turkey syria said no russia is an ally
of ours we won't do it then conveniently
for the u.s a civil war erupts in syria
and then the u.s is like well we got to
get rid of assad now oh it's funny how
that guy was blocking your pipeline and
now all of a sudden you oppose him and
you want to go to war there obama then
basically funds a lot of the really
awful stuff directly or indirectly
that's happening down there you get
syria collapsing then all of a sudden it
moves up into ukraine because that's
where the gazprom russian pipeline goes
through it's about a quarter i believe
around a quarter of the energy going
into europe the west wants to displace
that compete and lower prices
russia won't let them because russia's
allied with syria so now the u.s they
engage in conflict in syria so here i'll
tell you the funny thing
we sit here and you've got the american
corporate press going like russia is
invading ukraine and uh and it's like
and what did we do with syria that was
an ally of russia
and we were arming rebels we were
calling for bashar al-assad to be
removed saying he was all these really
awful things russia's doing the same
thing in ukraine right now this is all
part of the proxy war over energy and
some of uh some of our
weapons actually killed russians
yeah right so some of the russians were
killed by our weapons
world war three didn't break out yeah
because nobody wants world war three
right world war iii is bad for business
yeah what they want is small proxy wars
small proxy wars really good for
business we learned that after world war
ii right after what was small proxy war
is great for business so we want lots of
small proxy wars throughout the world
that works very well for the
military-industrial complex but i would
say
any possibility of a world war iii i
actually i'll put it this way some have
actually chatted with us and said that
world war iii started a while back it's
just that we're not in that generation
of warfare anymore so now what we're
seeing is propaganda media manipulation
cyber warfare
and i think it's fair to say that um if
that is modern warfare we are in world
war three well i would call it cold war
ii let me if i could right we had cold
war one after world war ii which was
soviet union or russia as number one
china's junior partner the
mad mutual assault destruction was
nuclear but the battlefield was
espionage right that was the battlefield
during that one we won that war right
but of course we had an advantage we had
better espionage we had more money we
had more nukes we were ahead cold war ii
started right after because what america
does well is when the world loses the
peace right so we lost the peace so now
we have world where now we have cold war
ii it's reversed china is now senior
partner russia is now junior partner the
mad mutual description is cyber when it
was nuclear and now we're fighting in
the markets and not in espionage so i
think we're in cold war too and you're
right we're losing
yeah
makes it feel a little more lukewarm
because in the cold war citizens weren't
getting screwed over by stuff really
they were ducking and covering in their
the nine-year-olds thinking they were
going to protect them from a nuke living
in terror but
they're shutting off the bank accounts
makes it feel kind of hot it's not hot
like a hot war would be when bombs are
dropping and houses are getting blown up
maybe
but i think maybe in the future uh if we
bring up often enough fourth and fifth
generational warfare hot means something
else i'm afraid of the ai really if
we're talking about a hot world war
three would be like people are stuck in
the metaverse and then the ai starts
dropping by ultron dude
yes but you remember that the the idea
of capturing land
is nowhere near as valuable as capturing
ip right ip is the value now right land
is less valuable than it ever was
compared to world war ii days right now
look what if the chinese invaded and
capture california do they care only if
the ip's gone
if the ip is still there they win if the
ip shifts to austin or something what
they get they got a bunch of expensive
land they have to quell that actually
sucks yes that's all they got northern
california is pretty good southern
california is basically drought ridden
yes so if they don't get the ip of
disney and of uh you know silicon valley
they don't get the ip what's the value
so they're trying to capture ip which
china is doing very well very very well
yeah disney
absolutely on board i loved it when
disney plus thanked the uh shinshank
security forces
for helping them with their movie and
it's like the same uh security
contractors that have you know the
uyghurs and concentration camps but talk
about ip capture there you go it's it's
a lot see this is the future of war it's
it's the control of resources
manipulation propaganda it's getting
lebron james to come out and defend
china right it's getting mark cuban and
who was the other guy was it steve steve
kerr was that his name
yeah and also uh right john cena oh yeah
yeah yeah steve kerr's the golden state
warrior coach yeah yeah i'm pretty sure
he came out and he was like look we got
a lot of problems in america too it's
like oh dude come on
yeah sure
but yo i think what's happened i don't i
don't even want to repeat the things
that are happening in in xinjiang i mean
that's just yeah nightmarish what's
going on with those people
but then you got uh what was her face
that that woman on was savannah guthrie
was that who did it that the olympic
opening ceremony was a weaker muslim so
she was like see look at that you know
repudiation oh wow there's a uyghur see
everything's fine yeah direct ccp
propaganda brought to you by nbc james
is black how could i be racist exactly
yes exactly
i think about world war ii and how i
would live my whole life like oh of
course i would support the invasion of
nazi germany and the you know the the
destruction of nazi germany or whatever
but like now today it's kind of like
we're looking at again do you support an
invasion do you support war do you
support putting your life on the line
and risking everything that we that we
have world war two most americans didn't
remember we never declared war in
germany
germany declared war on us yeah we
didn't we didn't care about in that
stuff it wasn't for we declared war on
japan because japan attacked us first
correct we didn't remember the speech
the day that we'll live in infamy yeah
his words were i won the declaration of
war against the empire of japan
hitler declared war on us
we didn't declare war on him technically
we were funding the british and the
french as best we could the first
we were absolutely funding them but
declaration of war america wasn't
concerned about that remember all wars
begin
for terrible reasons but they always end
for ethical reasons
right so they began because someone
bombed us or let's go get the the
germans but it ends because freedom
that's not how it started
right so wars always end because of
something amazing but they begin because
of garbage
i think well one didn't didn't begin
to end the the empires yeah but now it
was the war and the empires yeah no it
was because people were being stupid in
in europe that's why i started right
three cousins couldn't couldn't get
along with each other three cousins
couldn't like each other yeah that's a
good point like at what point if you
have a defensive pack with the country
do you renege on the defensive pact or
don't have one i'm not going in yeah you
got involved like ukraine you have one
like nato nato is a defensive pact and
we should not be in it
i i'm interested i'm interested in that
path yes wasn't that wasn't that trump's
position as well yes well trump was
better trump wanted them to pay more
right i think he didn't go far enough oh
wow i would have removed ourselves out
of nato completely why are we in nato
was was a pact to stop the soviet union
when the soviet union fell we should
have removed ourselves from nato all
nato has done it started problems for us
i mean you know one thing i was saying
earlier is why should any american care
about what's happening on the eastern
borders of ukraine when our southern
border is
not a priority for this president for
this administration
the idea that they would be sending us
troops to eastern europe for some threat
of russia but not be willing to secure
our own borders laughable well there's
two parts i want to bring up here i do
care
and we should care it doesn't mean we
should send young marine soldiers and
sailors to die
right and there's and there it's not
black and white in my view i think we
can use the bully pulpit we can talk
about it we can try to make it better we
get the american people to care we can
do that and assist but i don't want to
say look i was a marine
and when i was a marine would i have
left my legs in the streets of manhattan
i'm a new yorker would have done that of
course i do today right if i thought the
chinese were coming across the border or
something i'd leave my legs and streets
of manhattan today and i'm an old man
now and i would still do it but do i
want to send my kids who my kids are now
17 years old do i want to send my
children to go fight and die in ukraine
no
i don't but do i care of course i care i
don't want them to have trouble i don't
want them to be bombed i'm a human being
i have compassion i don't want them to
die but it doesn't mean i want to send
my children to die what i might want to
do is try to help them defend themselves
maybe i'm okay with that right or talk
about it or whatever the case may be
but people have the right to fight their
own wars and to create their own
governments we had a civil war we had a
revolutionary war that's how we started
our country we won't let others do it
we were under the under the yoke of the
british empire for 100 years and then we
decided that the best way for us to
become independent was war the canadians
thought nah we'll do a peace
both for the right answer each nation
decides on its own then we had to have a
civil war the canadians didn't have to
have one that's fine both are the right
answer apparently we were hanging out
with um stephen marsh he wrote a book on
civil war yep and he was mentioning i
read his book canada actually had some
very serious periods of instability in
what was it 82 and 95 yep so
you know it's not all perfect
no nation is yeah no nation is if you've
got to put people together they're going
to want to fight each other it's how it
works now hopefully we can do it
peacefully through politics and through
talking that's the best way of doing it
and that's what canada decided that's
good we didn't i got a feeling in
ukraine that the russian is going to
send peacekeepers in and then americans
are going to be funding the rebels for
the next 20 years again and arming them
and then the rebels are going to become
the villains when we're done with it you
know i just want to i just want to say
man
uh
ukraine is amazing beautiful country i
got to hang out in kiev for for several
months
amazing food
poverty wages good people
beautiful cities and absolutely horrible
uh you know what we're seeing here man
it was kind of crazy to see that
this this country what was it luke was
saying was like the afghanistan of
europe
i went for a walk when i was in kiev
with uh some co-workers and a friend and
we're going to get we're going to get
food and you can see buildings that
still have bullet holes from wow from
world war ii i think it was or whatever
that when there was like artillery
firing that they just never repaired
some of these like inside it's fine but
outside you can see the scars of war
and it's kind of sad because these
people are um
you know the people i met and hung out
with are just
good hard-working people who want to
just do their thing but i think
sometimes they want to keep their own
purpose right they they don't want you
to forget but there are aspects of if
you go to germany um parts of where the
brother and wall used to be yeah they
keep that stuff there so you don't
forget right they don't want you to
forget what happened so they will so a
lot of times people will purposely say
well i could fix that wall but
no you should look and go oh right war
is bad let's not do that i love it then
when they start
they start tearing down the statues in
the u.s
and they're saying like there's a meme
where it's like well what what about
moving the statues of uh of the nazis in
germany to museums oh wait there aren't
any because they destroyed it it's like
but as you mentioned there's parts of
the berlin wall there are still remnants
and you know look i i understand if
you've got a statue venerating can the
confederacy or the or some of these
people like the clan or something okay i
get we don't want those statues up in
the middle of a park or something but
you put them in a museum
if you're going to remove them and you
do it by vote you do it by a community
organization you say how many of us
agree on this the problem is you get
these lunatics who come in with ropes
and just rip them down against that's
anti-democratic it's fascistic it's
authoritarian as much as i
not a fan of the statues either i think
it's important if we don't put up a
plaque or have some remembrance of what
that was and why it was there
you're doomed to repeat your history i
like the idea of just auctioning them
all off
sucks them off raise money for the state
right which you need money anyway right
auction them all off and then if you're
some rich guy who cares about the
heritage which is often uncommon in most
states in this world right the the rich
guys will spend the time they will buy
it they'll move and they'll put into
their and they'll donate to the to the
museum but if you're some guy who really
hates some convenient general and you
want to tear a statue down great getting
the people together buy the statue and
have a ceremony in your front lawn and
yeah
look at this libertarian guy with a free
market solution you got it every time
guilty as charged thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you